[Music]
people have been steaming food for
thousands of years Once Upon a Time
Steamers were made out of clay pots with
perforated floors today we've come up
with all sorts of metal and plastic
Innovations the traditional bamboo
steamer is a perfect balance between the
old and the
new perfected by generations of
Craftsmen traditional bamboo steamers
are lightweight strong and durable
they look like simple cooking tools but
building them requires enormous
artisanal skill the Craftsman buys
lengths of bamboo from local farmers he
uses a traditional planer he crapped it
himself to smooth the bamboo
joints a customized Chopper tool helps
him split the bamboo
lengthwise he inserts a bamboo stick to
hold the split open after removing the
chopper he pulls on the stick to split
the entire length of the
bamboo the Craftsman splits the sections
again to assemble the steamer base the
Craftsman will split the bamboo into 32
pieces the cover will require 128
pieces a custommade knife knocks down
the intersections of the
bamboo for the steamer's cover the
Craftsman splits the bamboo horizontally
next the Craftsman uses this slicing
tool to cut the
wood he sets the desired width and
slices a thin sheet of wood
lengthwise he uses this section of wood
to form the base of the steamer and
slides a bamboo ring over it to hold it
in
place
then he punches small holes with the
drill and reinforces the joint with
stainless steel
[Music]
wire the installation process begins
first by installing a series of inner
Rings which will serve to reinforce the
structure of the steamer and to support
multiple levels of Steamers inside
it the Craftsman uses special techniques
to ensure that each joint is perfectly
aligned for maximum strength working
almost entirely by hand with skills
acquired over time he maticulously
creates a strong yet lightweight piece
of kitchen
[Music]
equipment the basket still needs a
bottom to rest dumplings in the
Craftsman begins building the basket
floor by custom fitting a series of
Rugged Cross pieces he ensures that each
piece fits FS perfectly before
proceeding then he inserts thin more
pliable pieces of bamboo to hold the
cross pieces in
place next he lays the final layer on
top placing the pieces with their outer
sides facing up to form a smooth surface
for food to sit on while
steaming with the floor of the steamer
in place it's time to secure the upper
Pieces by binding them to the support
pieces to do this he threads a stainless
steel wire through the cracks twisting
the ends tightly to the
base then he gives the inner support
Rings under the steamer floor a few Taps
securing them in
place the basket's base is now
complete
next the Craftsman begins weaving the
bamboo pieces together that will form
the
cover he uses a traditional pattern
called a twill
weave then he inserts paper before
adding a second layer of
[Music]
bamboo the paper will help prevent Steam
from escaping the basket too quickly he
then snaps in a series of carefully
sized reinforcements to keep the layers
in
place finally he custom fits another
interior ring under the reinforcements
to hold everything together tapping it
carefully into position the steamer
cover is now
complete people have used copper pots
and pans for thousands of years copper
is an ideal heat conductor allowing food
to be cooked quickly and evenly
copper pots allow for more precise
temperature control which means dinner
is less likely to be served
burnt in The Culinary World copper is a
precious metal besides being a great
conductor of heat copper pots look good
on the
cooktop to cut out a round blank a
Craftsman places a centering disc on a
copper
sheet he links it to a plasma torch
using a metal spindle the spindle holds
the torch at a specific distance so that
as the torch cuts out the circle the
radius is
exact the copper Smith ensures that the
cutout is as close to the edge of the
copper sheet is possible to minimize
waste next he examines the circular
blank the plasma cutting has left the
edges frayed
so he Smooths them by clamping the
copper blank in a
[Music]
lathe he Taps the blank with a rubber
mallet and centers it between the
clamping
Chucks the copper Smith uses a tool to
check that the blank is positioned
correctly then he adds oil to the
cutting tool and moves it against the
spinning blank it trims the
circumference creating a cleaner Edge
and removes any FL WS he files the rim
of the copper blank to make it smooth
and
even using sandpaper he finishes the
edge with the imperfections removed the
copper blank is formed into a saucepan
with sloping
sides two Craftsmen press a roller
against the copper blank so that it
conforms to the shape of a mold that's
part of one of the clamping Chucks this
process is called metal spinning while
one Craftsman moves the roller across
the copper blank the other applies
pressure this shaping method takes 8 to
Rounds finally the pan has taken shape
but the forming process has left fine
lines on the surface so as it continues
to spin the copper Smith Smooths it
down he applies lubricant to a cutting
tool and trims the rim of the
saucepan this gives the pan the desired
height The Cutting leaves the edges very
sharp so he files them down
again the copper saucepan is ready for
the cast iron
handle cast iron has less thermal
conductivity than copper so the heat
from the pan will travel more slowly up
the
handle the Craft's person clamps the
handle to the saucepan this holds it
tightly in place as he drills rivet
holes through both the iron handle and
the copper
Pan the Craftsman removes the clamp and
bolts the handle to the pan
temporarily this stabilizes it for the
drilling of the second rivet
hole a Riv is inserted in the second
hole from the inside of the
pan the copper Smith heats the tail of
the rivet to soften
it then the pan is transferred to an
anvil using a Pneumatic Hammer the
copper Smith flattens the first rivet
removes the temporary bolt and installs
the second
rivet he heats the pan over a flame and
melts a tin bar to the bottom he spreads
the molten tin up the sides of the pan
using a rag that's been soaked with a
flux chemical the flux cleans the copper
and allows the tin to flow more
smoothly the tin lining will prevent
acidic foods from leeching raw copper
into the
food the heat from the tinning flame has
caused some
discoloration the copper Smith removes
the stains by using a cotton buffing
wheel and Polishing Compound as he
continues the polishing takes the copper
to a high
Sheen this copper sauce pan is now ready
for the stove top but first the
Craftsman pounds a steel stamp into the
bottom of the pan imprinting it with the
company
logo for cookware that only takes a
couple hours to make a copper pan can
last for decades and if it's well cared
for it won't even show its
age